it's tough to talk about the world of
cyberpunk without spending some time on
one of the major security corporations
of the future
militech if you've been following
gamespot's cyberpunk lore series you've
probably heard us talk about the weapons
manufacturer often
you may know militech as arasaka's
number one competitor but the
corporation's history runs much deeper
than that
[Music]
[Applause]
in 1998 the united states government
decided it was finally time to retire
the m16a2 assault rifle
marine corps officials were shipped a
handful of rifles to test out however
only three made it to the final trial
fn's sap colts ar-17x
and a firearm from a small weapons firm
called armatek lucey international the
sap was a cheap unreliable firearm its
only saving grace apart from being dirt
cheap was that the parts and ammunition
were compatible with the nato alliance
armaments
the ar-17x was an excellent gun with a
big
price tag although it passed the field
test with flying colors the united
states ultimately didn't think it was
worth the price
the weapon from armatech lucey
international proved to be the best of
both
worlds it was reliable and moderately
priced united states marine corps
general donald lundy a name you'll want
to remember took a liking to the
armatech lucey firearm
it was his number one choice however due
to the financial collapse at the time
the government settled on the sap and
drafted up a contract with fn
lundy unhappy with the government's
decision warned officials that putting
the sap in the hands of soldiers could
be disastrous
it turned out lundy was right thousands
of soldiers armed with the clunky sap
rifles died in south and central america
to make matters worse the european
community kicked the sap to the curb in
favor of the fnral
a fantastic weapon that was incompatible
with fn's sap
frustrated lundy left the marine corps
to work with armatech lucey
international
with his connections and experience he
was brought on as the acting ceo while
the founder antonio lukesi focused on
designing and creating weapons
thanks to lundy's connections to the
military he had no trouble securing
government contracts for armatech
lukkesi
these contracts gave the small arms
company a leg up over the competition
as armatech lucey international expanded
lundy and lucey decided it was time to
rebrand
and so militech was born militech's
first big break was to replace all the
saps the united states military bought
only a few years ago
i'm sure lundy walked into the pentagon
that day with a big old i told you so
grin on his face
militech's ronin light assault rifle
replaced fn's sap
and with that militech's popularity
skyrocketed worldwide
as militech grew and grew it swallowed
up smaller security corporations
soon competitors of all shapes and sizes
were being dismantled and absorbed by
the monstrous corporation
of course the lucrative government
contracts weren't the only thing making
militech a fortune many of their weapons
were sold and distributed to gang
members mercenaries everyday joes and
security departments and other companies
along with selling weapons and equipment
militech was known for hiring out their
private
military to anyone or anything with the
money to pay for it this includes but is
not limited to
assassinations revolutions civil wars
and according to the cyberpunk 2077
world book
ethnic cleansings yikes by 2020 militech
was the biggest weapons company in the
world
selling more firearms than any of their
competitors arasaka included
however money isn't everything and lundy
knew this militech's influence in reach
didn't quite match the arasaka family
and so a not so friendly rivalry between
arasaka and militech
came to be the rivalry came to a head
during the fourth corporate war
fighting between arasaka and militech
broke out all around the world in nearly
every major country
if you'd like to know more about this
conflict check out our video on the
fourth corporate war
in the meantime here are some important
bits arasaka and militech aligned with
nautical tech companies vying for market
control
early on arasaka and militech launched a
clandestine war against each other known
as the shadow war
eventually tensions bubbled over and the
two corporations kicked off a
full-fledged corporate-backed war
fighting persisted until a mysterious
pocket duke erupted in arasaka's night
city headquarters killing half a million
people
in response the acting president
nationalized militech and kicked arasaka
out of the united states
on paper militech won arasaka's reach
was reigned in significantly giving
militech an
opportunity to dominate the market
however militech's victory came at the
cost of their independence
president elizabeth cress had no plans
to surrender the corporation
after the fighting had stopped instead
she used militech's strength and
resources in an attempt to reunify the
united states if she was met with any
resistance she'd deploy militech troops
her regime wasn't entirely successful
many defected states including the free
state of northern california opposed
cress's campaign
ultimately crest slowed down on a
reunification plan as militech started
to regain its independence
however this wasn't the last time
militech got roped into a unification
war on behalf of the united states
government
let's skip ahead to 2069 recently
elected president rosalind myers
declared war on the free states of the
united states
many states were able to avoid fighting
or remain neutral by striking deals with
the federal government of the new united
states however the free states in need
of support looked to the mending arasaka
corporation with the devastation of the
fourth corporate war still somewhat
fresh president myers drafted up a
treaty and the war was put to bed
currently not much is known about
militech's presence in 2077.
according to the cyberpunk 2077 world
book the united states government still
has some control over militech but not
to the same extent as it did before
i have no doubt that militech will play
a big role in 2077 but i'm curious to
see how v
story may get intertwined with the
massive corporation especially if you
pick the corpo life path
if you'd like to learn more about
cyberpunk's lore check out our other
videos including one on militech's rival
arasaka and the deadly cyborg atom
smasher and with that we'll see you next
week
[Music]
you